in March of 2020 our lead National
correspondent that's David begno went to
Cookeville Tennessee after an ef-4
tornado hit the city east of Nashville
19 people in Cookeville were killed that
day including the Kimberlin family
that's Josh Aaron and two-year-old
little Sawyer David recently returned to
visit family members of the victim to
see how the community is now honoring
their memories
our trip back to Cookeville Tennessee
began with a door knock
at the home of Pastor Rodney Pitts there
he is and his wife Trish thank you nice
to meet you wow it's been a long time
coming it has been nearly three years
since we reported on that tornado
which killed their daughter Aaron
Kimberlin her husband Josh and their
two-year-old son Sawyer
he loved the Church Hymnal one song in
particular
that was his song that was his song he
couldn't read other places that had a
different songbook
he would look through it and find that
because he knew what it looked like the
pits took us to where the kimberlin's
home once stood until the tornado ripped
it off its foundation
that sacred ground where they died is
now a living Memorial this was a area
where Sawyer played a lot and they've
made just a beautiful Park out of that
to kind of
make it a happy place for kids
we can come out and smile you know it's
good and where the children now play
Trisha and Rodney Pitts often come to
pray
and then just reflect I'm not the same
person I used to be that's for sure
what's changed
oh man
everything
you know
you preach about the
how life is a vapor that it's just a
it's come and gone and it's it's you
tell people all along how how fragile
and uncertain it is
now I know it is in March 2020 in the
dark of night while so many people were
asleep the tornado blasted through with
175 mile per hour winds and destroyed
170 homes that was just big tall piles
of just Rubble everywhere and it was the
oddest thing David there was no grass
it actually it pulled the grass and and
I just remembered Trish has just kept
saying there's nothing here
there's nothing left
and in your mind you're thinking
well there's somewhere yeah they they're
not here they weren't here you know but
but they were how does it feel to have
people
still thinking about them
and talking about them and checking up
on y'all it means so much to know that
their memories still alive and the
impact that they had on people
was enough that they still think of them
the community also built a memorial
garden for the five children who died
Sawyer
Hattie Joe Collins
Dawson Curtis
Bridget and Marie McCormick Phillips
and Harlan Marsh
eventually it'll be a nice Shady spot
yeah they also planted trees for all 19
people who died that night
like Alicia rittenberry Who Loved
karaoke
Sue and Todd Kohler who married in 2017.
Amanda Cole was the live-in nanny for
the Curtis family
she died along with Terry Curtis and his
son Dawson and three trees for the
Kimberlin family they died on March 3rd
the next day is what
March 4th
and that's what we're doing
we're marching forward
day at a time Kim Cantley is Josh
kimberlin's mom how do you describe how
much you miss him he was my Peter Pan
he just brought laughter
and just did it so
just so naturally
God made Aaron for Josh and
you know there's a lot of tragedy in the
story of March 3rd but there's a lot of
beauty too they would have never made it
you know one made it and the other
didn't God took them together
all three
[Music]
I hear their laughter and
it is a beautiful story Tim doesn't know
if you've been a good boy or a bad boy
this year can you Enlighten us the sound
that's a pretty strong case the memories
you say prayer all bittersweet
well you know we came back to really
check on those left behind
to just see how you're doing
because of their faith
because of God's word
we're doing we're doing good we are
doing good it gives us hope
yeah
death is something we'll all experience
but it's not the end
no I'll see them again
Aaron and Sawyer are buried together
Josh is right beside them
this is the photo that tells the story
of those who rest here
we couldn't ask for any better I mean
very very blessed all of our children
have married really it's wonderful
families but these
um
it's deeper you may be wondering how do
they deal with the unbearable pain happy
birthday Daddy we love you I'm ready to
see you this afternoon well they're the
lucky ones yes with unshakable faith
God's been very good to us to give us
everything we've needed through this
process and he's put up with me
it's those home videos that will get you
every time when you see the family live
and in color and the love that they had
for each other and I always Marvel at
people's faith during those times I
really do I Marvel at people's desire to
want to help six to seven thousand
volunteers showed up to help that
Community 2.3 million dollars was raised
and it was all shared amongst the
families who lost the strength the
resilience the woman standing there in
front of you crying but saying we're
good that's such an amazing power that
they have to move forward March 4th as
she said March 4th I thought that was
interesting I hope you feel hope after
watching this it's not about the sadness
the pits want you to feel hope because I
know they do because they've got it they
do David well done they have to take
their lead art we have to take the lead
from them on them all right David